hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to west of loathing now
we got to turn in there you go don't
know what that's all about but there you
go huh looks like these things are still
twitching better lock him up just to be
safe
cuz they're gonna go in the ghost shell
cell oh they are oh the Gherkin brothers
sell weird goddammit I really wish I
didn't kill those last ones dammit
I didn't mean to I didn't know there was
any other way that's not like Adam the
item or anything of those gonna help me
sneak snog oh well there's only one more
so let me finish that up before I go
anywhere else
the potemkin gang come across a goblin
hey hey human what are you doing in this
place it's ground my ground is stomping
what do you mean you're stomping grounds
what Gary talk to this guy
your boots how tall they are to looking
at yes yes the tallest boots how is it
such tall boots you had two having two
winning them in a jelly stomping contest
you're in the Goblin chatter for a while
about boots and jelly and now stomping
relates to both of them
okay alright antic of interest a fellow
of very interest would you like to
hearing a more jelling stomping no not
at all
I got a guffin what's a guffin what'd I
do with a guffin oh oh oh
genuine TNT and sandwiches Town Hall for
an actual town peculiar you duck into
the outhouse to plan your next move
while you're pondering you notice
something weird this outhouse has a back
door through the back door Oh hefty load
the back of the jail turns out just flat
plywood like a theatrical set the ropes
are holding this thing up don't look
strong you can knock it over pretty
easily but you should probably hold off
until just the right moment okay
alrighty then just the right moment you
say well this is peculiar and backwards
and weird oh look a plunger this doesn't
seem safe at all you know what I'm
pretty sure I'd agree with that
sentiment alright hello the bandit looks
distraught what's the matter buddy
I lost my belt buckle Oh
did you look near the sandwich shop oh
good idea look there oh hello
[Laughter]
aye sir no entry alrighty then whatever
you say buddy
whatever you say alright well I probably
shouldn't blow them all up
did you look near the jail
yikes yikes
get away from me I'm not in trying it
the guy says sorry it's really very
condemned the sandwiches were terrible
anyway Oh were they huh how peculiar get
away from me
ah okay ah he runs over whenever I see
okay alright well you all stay there by
the real jail I'm gonna go back and see
if I can do something about all dis all
right see in a second - guys I'm not
gonna blow you up because that'd be mean
but how about I knock it over cut the
ropes
um crash falls over on the real bandits
alright okay don't know why I bothered
to build this fake down nobody ever let
me into it
weird alright hello you all okay you
dead here you dead y'all dead oh they're
dazed and confused take him to jail
alright
goddamnit I got everybody except ah oh
hey good to see you know if you really
cleaned up the area I plumb out of
bounties for you does that mean I get to
be Sheriff no but I guess he could be
marshal if you want oh what a
coincidence
that's my middle name mark what mum
Fleur sneaky Marshall bum Porton
Humperdinck yeah that's it that's the
one thanks again for all your help
Marshall you got it sorry about that bag
of ears and bones Ida Liberty you meant
to make that living people but you know
how it goes you know how it be alright
let's see if see if this goddamn circus
ready yet oh my L vibrate Oh
all right we got aliens whoa
Gary getting strong baby I am that'll
that'll make it good right okay well I
got some L fry burrito scraps I don't
have enough to get back to the guy but
no I'm gonna see about this it ready yet
no okay all right whatever all right
let's go forward we either go to the
railroad camp all right what's got you
stop now railroad people
Yipes huge the guys stopped messing with
his watch and started eating jelly beans
what you got there jelly beans yep can I
have one nope please no get your own
well I'm never well I never where'd you
get him
Roy beans house of justice and jelly
beans well that's bizarre
all right howdy boss howdy Smith nook
again yep
got ourselves one hell of a canyon to
get across and no materials for bridge
building any idea this is an old mind
town up north called bread wood they
opened up a lumber camp after the mines
dried up if you can fix a deal with them
for the lumber we need I can handle the
engineering side of things okay where is
it it's me marks location of bread would
camp on your map of course anything you
find to build a bridge out of it's fine
by me but that seems like the simplest
option can I build it out of bones can I
do that
one of those pay telescopes this one is
designed by a promising young artist
named after munch you pay your meat look
through the telescope at the big Canyon
it sure is big it'll take quite a bridge
to cross that thing that's for sure
there's gonna be a lot of bones I'm
gonna make that out of all right well
let's go to bread wood because that
seems like an actual town so that might
happen I might have some better stuff Oh
open it up okay cool got a ranch pouch I
sure do love my portable ranch
you excited about that Tim Fleur that
standing horse give you hoping dream for
your your future hello are you the mayor
howdy mayor I'm mum Fleur pumper ding
here on behalf of the manifest destiny
railroad company we need to build a
bridge and hurry so I'm here to cut a
deal with you for the real umber alright
I believe we can scrape together that
much wood well sort of down payment or
off or in oh uh I sort of expected you
would just bill us you want that much
lumber with no upfront payment are you
serious I can probably offer you free
train rides I do enjoy a nice train ride
but that deal would be a real problem
and I've already got some problems to
worry about the mayor glances at the
list of problems supposed to on the wall
of paces around nervously offered to
help with his problems maybe I could
help you well thank you I certainly
welcome any assistance you can how far
my problems got a lot of problems look
at the problem board you glanced at the
problems board to which offers a
selection of current problems as well as
dire warning which with problems do no
work with dire warning wait what dire
warning what dire warning missing mail
overdue book logging permit soup
shortage skeleton raid stolen yeast
milling bread I'll do the mail I guess
our last batch of mail never got here we
don't know if something happened to the
mailman or what go dr. Reginald in the
bunkhouse he used to be a mailman so we
can tell you where to start your search
okay alright that's a lot of problems
there's a note last time a mayor let
this list go over three items we chased
him out of town with his bread stick
nailed at the top of his head right well
this is bizarre you know what towns got
into pot when the horses are drunk
alright sure we'll go at that one well
well looks like some poor son of a
biscuit wandered into town had a cake
sucker Wow jeez rude and baffling get
used to it
we lock our custon here in bread would
share fine
but cake sucker we also lock our breads
a bread related products so I've noticed
I'll buy a drink bartender pours a shot
of something and slaps it on the bar in
front of you I don't get to choose no
all right
thank you thank you very much all right
howdy Gary oh hey another goblin tellin
Gary once about a place near here what
kind of place very weird place all
seeing through it
okay all right well ghost what it is
then all right cool just two friends
reminiscing about good old times and
occasionally showing one another their
guns in a non-threatening way alrighty
then whoa all right then
it's probably dangerous to interrupt
this CC bartender four darts
this guy's Grimsley washing dishes he
notice you're looking and waves away you
irritatedly
alright we don't take kindly to
strangers stranger don't need your kind
around here did you say need or need
well anyway signed on the paint got no
dots okay what about the guy washing
this is that muffin lover ran up a tab
he couldn't pay off so now here gets to
wash dishes
some of them dishes I've been saving for
just an occasion I must is he owned 150
I'll bet you're even dumber and I soon
but whatever you can tell him he's free
yourself alrighty
take good bye now hello you're free huh
what you do a thing like that for I was
just feeling charitable I guess well
thanks but I don't know how to do pretty
much nothing sip washing dishes nothing
at all well I can also wash clothes I
can play the washboard that's pretty
much it though well it's plenty of job
opportunities open up in dirt water why
don't you try your luck there
well alright worth the shop thanks belt
okay goodbye I'm in it's another dune
I'm gonna take a closer look look this
isn't mom-and-pops family funtime saloon
this is a dive bar in a dive town the
people who drink in here are mainly
drifters and Desperados don't go
splashing around in the littoral scum of
the scum of the earth I'm gonna
seriously don't this is wrong and
disgusting it is vile behavior I have my
face right up to the thing what's it
look like
no I'm not telling you why are you doing
this to me I had to skip lunch today
because I couldn't stop thinking about
you and these foul spittoons splashing
around la la la la
I'm not listening you find nothing
you're the worst person in the world ha
ha ha I fell
I found something all right
like a necrotic skin disorder I bet
actually it's a pair of boots so there
mr. delicate stomach boots great boots
full abandoned spit oh they have a whole
new kind of trench foot just for you
I hope they named it after you you're
just jealous of my sweet new boots
[Music]
three maximum ap that's incredible I
will put on must spit boots I love it I
got so much good stuff hey wait that's
not my filthy filthy porcelain cow there
we go now I feel better
oh jeez a little bit where these guys up
to ask him the man with the black hat as
a huge pile of meat in front of him
the man with the white hat looks broken
sad what'd you play in fellas Ferro but
I wouldn't say we're playing I'd say we
did play until this cowpoke ran out of
money
how's it work it's easy you bet fifty
meat and then you say name then you name
as many pharaohs as you can every time
you name one I'll give you 20 me wait
what those are the rules had this guy
lose all of his meat to you he's real
bad at it I'll give it a try all right
partner it's our name in pharaohs
Tutankhamun what everybody knows that
one what else you got uh sniffing can
free you don't actually know the names
of any more pharaohs Smith sniffing can
free he grumbles and hands you you're
winning
amendments it's all right zip them and
that's all I got
tables cloves get lost Oh still mad
about losing better leave them alone oh
there's a trading post oh wait no hang
on genius at work here Fred wood trading
post it's a post trade with it you got
it buddy
I'm gonna give that I'm gonna get
punching desert eatin and drink foraging
finally monkey wrench
all right I'll wrench you mushroom
plucking
whoo I want both of these by oh and I
have enough money for it and let me see
wait let me redo all these books read
these foraging yes finally goddamnit
unfortunately while practicing your
techniques you actually squeeze the book
and a book juice which it turns out
isn't a real thing
oh man okay fine brawny
which increases your maximum HP menacing
mood thick skin creases your arm armor
big thick skin you conveniently pull you
pull even conveniently include a sheet
of sandpaper out of the book and rub
your skin with it until it's nice and
thick you got thick skin then you try to
put the sandpaper back in the book and
end up ruining the whole thing oh good
stuff Gary you get that all right
delicious discs Gary I know I don't
write oh that's so footy all right
anyway uh might be something I can sell
for that uh the mushroom pliers ah okay
that's enough all right got it
BAM okay I got the mushroom picking
thing that's good to know
I owe you one piano then how does a
piano playing in here well that's weird
all is not well with this well all is
not well with anything then rather that
okay what did they get here flush it
just for fun
I got a perk master of flushing zipping
your toilet flushing muscles are in
fantastic shape sure okay oh geez oh
it's funny wash up
ah much better hello howdy are you
Reginald who the fukushi are you names
monthly lumber ding the mayor's got me
investigating some missing mail said you
can give me a line on where to start
looking
oh yeah all right I gave up being a
mailman a couple years ago but I doubt
they change the system much all the mail
added here used to go through a
Waystation just sound sweater here I'll
mark it on your map all right thank you
guys just chillin by the fire must not
be a very good fire this guy seems very
focused on this beard
all right howdy stranger I'm Hobart
Boober you're what I mean hi Hobart am
um Fleur pumper dink you seem like the
traveling saw mom doing a fellow favor
what's the favorite thing is my only
dream in life is to see an owl skeleton
that's quite a dream I heard they got
one at the petting cemetery but but what
Patton cemetery is that what it sounds
like
exactly what it sounds like but see I
ain't got the meat for a ticket you want
alone no I ain't got no prospects paying
it back but I got a camera and I figured
if you under the cemetery you could take
a picture of their house skeleton and
bring it back to me okay I'll do that
I got an owl camera it's it's camera
with an L shaped aperture okay I
discovered the Patton cemetery okay I'll
be back okay
I'll be back okay I'll be back David I
need better lock-picking that's what I
need where is my lock-picking ah damn it
I need a little more XP I'll get that in
just a bit
ah I love this game so much God did
little Louise oh oh why are you dead
done what's done which Cruden croissant
lebreton
what graves pass here too old to still
be legible oh I don't have this level of
foraging damn it god I wish I was like a
snake oiler
instead of a cowpuncher cow butchered
basic [ __ ] that could be something so
better anyway what was I talking about
let's go to the let's go to the
ghostwood first just cuz that sounds
interesting
what do you got it whoa you might expect
to just be able to walk straight through
but the door of a ghost building but
some kind of force is preventing you I
guess you can knock on the force knock
your fist makes a distant echo II plops
up in the bar room door what a ghostly
voice comes out of nowhere howdy there
fella
new in town yeah I was wondering if
sorry I can't do business with you until
you have a visitor identification card
ain't supposed to even talk to you
really okay where do I get one drive to
town oh oh all the buildings in town are
weird and hazy and translucent like Oh
ghosts it's a literal ghost town okay
alright thank you
ghost houses weird right never heard of
a ghost anything except people gary was
seeing a ghost cactus once yeah there's
one down the end of the street - how
does the cactus die with unfinished
business did not poking enough people
buy that I'll buy that what's this
that's a ghost rock the ghost drop
alright fine then oh my god with the
ghost down all there's a regular cactus
well the ghost of a regular cactus well
the ghost of a regular Casius with the
ghost of a pencil stabbed into it take
that try to grab the pencil but your
hand keeps slipping through it almost as
if it's a goddamn ghost Oh looks to be
the ghost of a town hall looks like a
regular town all except you know the old
ghost thing knock your fist makes a
distant echo app you'll be needing a
visitor identification card I guess so
I'll be abie to fill in the forms most
living people have trouble holding the
pages you'll be needing no no three pens
so if you're filling in the form can't
you just use your own pencil I will be
but the instructions say very clear
the applicant must have our number three
bands oh and number three number two the
usual kind I suppose but a number three
percent 50 percent more official we're
gonna get one the dark part meant of
requisitions it's just a store you mean
the general store it's a little more
specific these days but yes all right
what about this pencil I want it all
right fine office supply hello sorry
can't help you unless you have a visitor
ID but I need a pencil for no visitor ID
no supplies okay well we've got an issue
see the general store won't give me a
pencil without of his ID no certainly
not they're not authorized in deal with
anyone who does 11 IDs so how am I
supposed to get a number through pencil
I suppose I can issue a temporary
visitor permanent you don't need a
pencil for that one okay great
what's your last name my last name its
bumper dang bumper ding my first tip is
muffler middle name it's Marshall and
sneaky it's also Marshall where are you
from a little farm outside boring
Springs I live wherever the odd farm
boring Springs never heard of it what's
it like well it's not much so I miss it
already
that's nice thank you all right how many
bars are in the window the adjunct
Department of Records
well it's a quiz to make sure you have
actually been paying attention to and
care about our little town
sad just breezing on through seven
you're a science
oh god damn it fine whatever one two
three four five six okay six and/or ten
if you count the doors all right thumper
dink mom Fleur
Marsh all boring Springs miss it in the
window you got six correct alright
everything seems to be in order here
your temporary visitor pass it expires
in 11 seconds oh god it's expiring help
help help last name for birding oh it
expired god damn it
excuse me fine what's your last name
Farber ding mom flirt Marshall boring
Springs I miss it what 6c is it okay
it's Farber dink what I do this bumper
dink mom fleur Marshall little farm miss
it already
what six okay Can I grab this I got it
it's a number four oh it's at number
four now to number three no something
you wouldn't notice look at number four
is like 33% more official right nice try
but it doesn't work like that
alrighty then nobody's home excuse me
but never heard of you alright fine then
stable see go away you're aren't
authorized shoo
well that's rude okay sharpen a pencil
ooh I got a sharp and ghost pencil
woo wait a sure I guys sharpened a
quarter off of it that makes it three
right that works right write a number
three pencil here it is that's a number
four pencil know it's 75% of a number
four pencil I see hmm I don't see
anything about this in the bylaws very
well I suppose you two let's get you
started on that visitor identification
thank God
last name bumper dick first name Blum
Fleur mentally Marshall mum floor
Marshall Humperdinck yep that matches
what it says here good where you from
foreign Springs heard of that here it's
real crap hole all right how many bars
are in this we know the adjunct
Department of records sex we why
white bumper take mumbler
Marshall boring Springs Oh in the
adjunct Department of Records
ah eight oh one two three ten hey ten
correct alright everything seems to be
in order allow me to officially welcome
into the town of ghostwood here's your
visitor ID thank you
say was it called ghost Witter yes total
coincidence okay well I got bad now so
good can't think of anything for you
shut up all right what can I do for you
nothing I guess
can I help you I can't think of anything
knock Oh what can I do for you I need a
drink immediately I don't know why I did
all this beer whiskey beer alright just
got to take your name down for the
requisition slip lasting lumber take
birthday month ler middle name Marshall
let me match that against your video
visitor ID
yep that's fine I don't have the meat
for it that's a lot of money for god
damn you all right I'm gonna in that
episode here
god damn it oh my god that was insanity
but I love it so I'll pick this up in
the next episode oh wait there's
something I can kill ah good let me just
murder this real quick it's under with
Oh
Gary's real straw for attacks holy [ __ ]
Gary get them get it and get them all
right hey thank you everybody so much
for watching thank god this game is
hilarious
so thanks everybody for watching let me
know I did in the comments below and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
[Music]